SPEAKER 1: Our next speaker
is something of a rebel,
I think, in the
scientific community.
William Happer is
professor emeritus
in the Department of Physics
at Princeton University.
And prior to coming
to Princeton,
he taught at Columbia
University and served
as director of the Columbia
Radiation Laboratory.
He has some government
experience, some recent
and some from
about 30 years ago.
He served as director
of energy research
in the US Department of
Energy from 1991 to 1993.
And then most recently,
from 2018 to 2019,
he was deputy assistant to the
president and senior director
for emerging technologies at the
White House National Security
Council.
He told me at dinner
last night that he's
more convinced than ever
after his most recent service
that there is a deep
state and it's much worse
than it was 30 years ago.
He's a co-founder of the
nonprofit CO2 Coalition, which
seeks to educate
policymakers and the public
about the vital contribution
made by carbon dioxide
to our lives and our economy.
And I just want to say I'm also
in favor of carbon dioxide.
He is a co-founder of
Magnetic Imaging Technologies
Incorporated, which
specializes in the use
of laser-polarized noble gases
for magnetic resonance imaging.
He also invented the
Sodium Guidestar,
which is used in astronomical
adaptive optics systems
to correct for the
degrading effects
of atmospheric turbulence
on imaging resolution.
And I'm hoping he's
going to tell me
at least what that means.
The author of more
than 200 peer-reviewed
scientific papers, he's
a member of a number
of professional societies
and associations.
His topic today is How To
Think About Climate Change.
Please Welcome Dr.
William Happer.
WILLIAM HAPPER:
Thanks so much, Tim.
Well, I certainly
appreciate the honor
of speaking to this gathering,
getting to know a little bit
more about Hillsdale
College, which, of course,
I knew about before,
but not in such detail
as I've learned over
the last day or two.
The title of my talk is How
To Think About Climate Change.
And let me see if
this clicker works.
I hope it works.
Good, OK.
So the first thing to--
the best way to think about
the frenzy over climate
is it's kind of a modern version
of the medieval crusades.
You remember that the
motto of the crusaders
was Deus Vult, "God Wants It."
And it's hard to pick a
better virtue-signaling slogan
than that.
But so far, most of
the climate enthusiasts
have not gone that far.
Some have, actually.
They claim they're
doing God's work.
Because of decades
of propaganda,
many Americans,
perhaps including
some of you here today,
think there really
is a climate emergency.
Those who think that way, in
many cases they mean very well.
But they've been misled by
decades of misinformation.
So as a scientist who actually
knows a lot about climate,
and I set out many of our
climate research centers
when I was at the Department
of Energy in the early 1990s,
I can assure you that there
is no climate emergency.
There will not be a
climate emergency.
And crusades have
always ended badly.
They brought discredit to
the supposed righteous cause.
They brought hardship
and death to multitudes.
And policies to address this
phony climate of emergency
will cause great damage
to American citizens
and to their environment.
But it's heating up.
On February 4, Bernie Sanders
and Alexandra Ocasio-Cortez
and Congressman Blumenauer from
Oregon introduced legislation--
I quote from
Blumenauer's website--
"legislation mandating
the declaration
of a national
climate emergency."
The National Climate
Emergency Act
directs the president
of the United States
to declare a national
climate emergency
and mobilize every resource at
the country's disposal to halt,
reverse, mitigate, and
prepare for the consequences
of this climate crisis.
Well, there isn't
a climate crisis.
There will not be
This is utter nonsense.
[APPLAUSE]
It gets worse when you
get to the state levels,
where there's a little
less checks and balances.
These are remarks made
last week by Charles Ismay,
the undersecretary for climate
change in Massachusetts.
And it was made to the
Vermont Climate Council.
So I'll read it to you.
So let me say that again.
50% of our emissions
that need to be reduced
come from you, the person
across the street, the senior
on fixed income, right.
There's no bad guy left,
at least in Massachusetts,
to point the finger at,
to turn the screws on,
and to break their wills
so they stop emitting.
That's you.
We have to break
your will, right?
I can't even say that publicly."
Well, a few days later,
Mr. Ismay resigned.
And had he not, his governor
would have fired him.
But that's the way crusades are.
This is really not a
question of science.
This is a question of a
secular religion for some.
It's a question of
money for others.
power for others.
But whatever it is,
it's not science.
So during the medieval
Crusades, part of it
was against the supposed threat
to the holy sites in Jerusalem.
But a lot of it was
against local enemies.
So the medieval Inquisition
really great job
on the poor Cathars and the
Waldensians of Southern France
and the Bogomils in the Balkans.
And climate fanatics don't
know or care any more
about the science
of climate than
these medieval
inquisitions knew or cared
about the teachings of Christ.
So just about everyone wants
to live in a clean environment.
I do.
I'm sure everyone here does.
And this is a photograph--
I hope it shows
up on the screen.
I don't see it just yet--
of Shanghai.
And that's real air pollution.
You can just barely see
the bottle-opener building
in the back through
all the haze.
And some of this is actually
due to burning coal.
But a bigger fraction is due
to dust from the Gobi Desert.
They've had this type
of pollution in Shanghai
since the days of Marco
Polo and long before.
And part of it is
burning rice fields,
the stubble in the fields, which
is traditionally done there.
And this is the kind of
thing that I do not support.
I wouldn't want to live
in a city like that.
And if there's anything to
do that will make it better,
I would certainly support that.
But none of this has
anything to do with CO2.
CO2 is a gas you can't
see, smell, or taste.
So hairbrained schemes
to limit emissions
of CO2, which is
actually beneficial,
as I'll explain a
little bit later,
will only make it harder to
get rid of real pollutants,
like the pollutant I
showed you in Shanghai.
So let's talk about CO2.
Number one, it's not
a pollutant at all.
We breathe out lots of CO2.
Many people are
surprised to learn
that they exhale a little more
than two pounds of CO2 a day.
So you people in this room
are putting out a lot of CO2.
I actually brought
a CO2 meter here,
which I'm going to turn on.
It takes about 30
seconds to warm up.
But we will see
what the levels are.
Before I came down here,
my wife, Barbara, and I
measured the CO2 on
our balcony outside.
And it's about 400 parts per
million outside this building.
So this is warming up now.
I'll show what the results
are here in a minute.
But our breath is not that
different from the output
of a power plant.
Power plants take in
normal air, and they
burn a fair amount of the oxygen
out of the air in burning coal,
or natural gas, or oil.
And the result that
comes out of the stack
is mostly the nitrogen
that was already there,
a little bit of oxygen
that wasn't used up,
and water vapor, and CO2.
And our breath, except for
having a lot more oxygen--
so you can give
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation.
You couldn't do it if your
breath was like a power plant.
It's very similar
to the power plant.
It's about 4% CO2, 6% water.
Power plant has a bit more
CO2 and correspondingly less
oxygen.
But our breath is
definitely not a pollutant.
In fact, our breathing reflex
is entirely determined by CO2.
It's not determined
by oxygen at all.
It's not a lack of
oxygen, it's too much CO2
that makes you exhale.
This is a picture
of my wife, Barbara,
in New Jersey on
a new solar farm.
And we'd just seen how well
solar farms and windmills
work in Texas.
[LAUGHTER]
And they never did
work terribly well.
But we have to be
grateful for nature.
She seems to have
a sense of humor
and has taught us a
good lesson, I hope,
although people seem
to be slow learners.
But the problem with renewable
energy-- solar, wind--
is they take up a lot of space.
I preferred this field
when it was nice and green
instead of these weedy panels.
They're quite weedy now.
This was soon
after it was built.
They don't work at all at night.
So you need something else
to provide electrical power
at night.
They don't work if
it's a cloudy day.
They don't work terribly well in
the winter when the sun is low.
So it's pure virtue signaling.
They make no economic sense
unless you've massively
subsidized by the state
and federal governments.
Here is an early wind
farm in California.
It's beginning to
fall to pieces.
But all wind farms
Nobody quite knows
how we're going
to dispose of all of this
junk when it no longer works.
It has much the same
problems as solar.
When I was a kid,
people didn't sit
in front of computer
screens all day
and look at simulations
of the world.
But you could go outside
and look at the clouds,
or what the weather was like.
In those days, people knew that
the wind bloweth as it listeth.
Sometimes it blows,
sometimes it doesn't.
And we just saw last week,
it didn't blow very much.
And when it was
trying to blow, it
was blowing on iced-up windmill
blades and didn't do any good.
So renewable energy
is really what
I would call the inverse
Robin Hood strategy.
You've robbed from the
poor to give from the rich.
Utilities are permitted to raise
rates because of the capital
investments in inefficient,
unreliable renewables.
They junk fully depreciated
coal, gas, and nuclear plants,
all of which are
working beautifully,
producing inexpensive,
reliable energy.
But regulated profits
are much less.
So taxpayers subsidize
the rich, who
can afford to lease land
for wind and solar farms.
The tax incentives is
pandered to the upper class
and gated communities
who can afford
to buy Tesla, electric cars
with subsidies from the state
and federal government,
often subsidies
for the electrical power
to charge up their toy.
And the common people
have little spare income.
They pay more and more for
the necessities of life
in order to subsidize
their betters.
Now, you can't spend a
lifetime as a professor
and not relapse
from time to time
to giving a classroom lecture.
So you will have to
expect to be lectured
to now for a few minutes.
And the good thing is
there will be no quiz.
But as you try to--
those of you who share my view
that this climate hysteria is
nonsense, it helps to
know what the facts are.
So I hope I can arm some of you
with the real scientific facts.
This is a picture of the overall
circulation of the atmosphere
around the Earth.
And the thing that keeps us
warm on Earth is the sun.
Everybody knows that.
Things warm up when the
sun comes up at dawn.
And it's nice and warm,
at least in summertime
and the early afternoon.
It cools off at night.
And the Earth is warm mostly in
the tropics, the reddish area
on this chart here.
That's where the sun is most
nearly overhead at noon.
And so there is
more solar energy
coming in at the tropics.
Then it goes out as
cooling radiation to space.
The sun-- the Earth
also radiates.
And if you've had dinner
here at the Marriott,
maybe you've sat under some
of the infrared radiators
on the outside patios.
And so you felt the
heat, radiant heat.
You can't see it, but you
can feel the radiation.
That's what Earth
radiates out to space.
So we cool.
Our Earth cools by radiating
out into very cold space
and by warming up from
the sunlight shining
during the half of the day.
So climate involves a
complicated interplay
of the sunlight that warms
us, the thermal infraradiation
that goes out into
space, and the transport
of this heat by both
radiation and by the motion
of the air and the water.
For example, I think we all
know about the Gulf stream that
carries huge amounts of
heat to northern Europe,
even to Russia.
And these currents of
air in the atmosphere
also carry a lot of heat.
Since we're in Phoenix,
let me point out
that if you look there, you
can sort of estimate where
Phoenix is, just over
the Mexican border.
It's where the color changes
from yellow to green.
And this is the descending
branch of that Hadley cell.
That's this air that rises
up near the equator--
hot air, moist
air, full of water.
So tremendous
rainfall down there.
And as the air
gets really high--
10, 15 kilometers-- most of
the water has been wrung out.
It's been freeze-dried out.
And then it heads
north or south.
And the air that
heads north eventually
falls back down to the Earth.
And typically, it
falls down over Phoenix
and over 30 degrees north
or 30 degrees south.
That's the great desert
belts of the Earth.
That's where the Sahara
is and the Chihuahuan
Desert and, to the south,
the Kalahari Desert.
And so these are
regions of Earth
which are underneath
these cascades of dry air
that was produced in the
tropics at the equator
and naturally went north.
It's a giant gas
turbine, but driven
by the sun and not spinning
any windmill blades, at least
at those altitudes.
Here is a picture of
Earth's energy budget.
I mentioned we're
warmed by the sun.
About half of the sunlight
eventually gets to the surface.
The thing that prevents it
all from reaching the surface
are clouds.
Other parts of America,
like New Jersey now,
are covered with clouds, so
you don't get any sunlight
directly.
And some of it is absorbed.
But the half that does reach
the ground, on average,
heats the ground.
And so the ground gets hotter.
You can notice that
in the afternoon.
If you go out, and if
you're a gardener like me,
you can put your
hands in the soil.
And it's nice and warm.
It makes the corn grow.
And that has to be released.
If you keep piling heat up,
it gets hotter, and hotter,
and hotter.
So it's released by
radiation to space, which
is that red arrow going up.
So the ground transports
solar heating upward.
Near the surface, the
first few kilometers,
a good fraction of
that heat is not
carried by radiation at all.
It's completely immune to
anything you do to CO2.
But once you get up to
10 kilometers or so,
most of that heat transport
goes into radiation,
this infrared
radiation I mentioned.
And by the way, I
have this running now.
The outside air is 400.
And I'm not sure
you can see this,
so I'll read it out to you.
But it's 580 in here.
So what this means-- this
is not a whole lot higher
than the 400 outside.
During lunch, we had this out.
And it was 1,000 where
we were having lunch.
But it makes the point that
CO2 levels are never stable,
you know?
People are panicking
about one or two parts
per million of CO2.
This is-- oh, now it's at 608.
That's probably because
I breathed on it.
[LAUGHTER]
Hot air sets it off.
These are interesting, too.
I sometimes take it
out on my back porch.
And at the end of a summer day,
the CO2 levels on my back porch
drop to maybe 300, way
below the outside air.
That's because the trees
and grass in my backyard
have sucked most of
the CO2 out of the air.
And then if I get up
early the next morning
and I look at the
meter, it's up to 600.
So just from morning to
night, CO2 doubles in the air.
It doubles and halves,
doubles and halves.
At least during the growing
season, that's quite common.
And we have these
hysterics about CO2
increasing by 30% or 40%.
It's amazing.
OK.
So why the frenzy over CO2?
The frenzy over CO2 is because
it is a greenhouse gas.
That is true.
CO2 is a greenhouse gas.
This is not-- it's a
somewhat deceptive picture.
But what it shows
in red is sunlight.
And the horizontal
scale on that top panel
is the wavelength
of the sunlight.
So sunlight is typically about a
half a micron, half a millionth
of a meter in wavelength.
That's green light, the
color of green leaves.
And the thermal radiation
that cools the Earth
is that blue curve to the
right of the upper panel.
And that's a much
longer wavelength.
That's typically
around 10 microns.
So it's 20 or 30 times
longer wavelengths
than the wavelengths
from the sun.
And it turns out
that the sun's energy
can get through the Earth's
atmosphere very easily.
So essentially, all
sunlight-- or at least 95%,
if there are no clouds-- gets
to the surface and warms it.
But the surface, trying to send
radiation back out to space,
is unable to get it freely to
space because various gases,
most importantly, water vapor--
which is shown as the
third panel down--
and CO2, which is the
fourth panel down,
intercept a lot
of that radiation
and keep it from freely
escaping to space.
So this keeps Earth's surface
temperature quite a bit
warmer than it would be,
about 20 or 30 degrees.
The Earth would be an
ice cube if it were not
for water vapor and CO2.
And when I say water vapor, you
should understand that I really
mean water vapor and clouds,
the condensed form of water.
So clouds are at least as
important as greenhouse gases.
And they're very poorly
understood to this day.
Greenhouse gases were discovered
in the 1850s by this man.
This is John Tyndall, who was
an Anglo-Irish physicist working
in London.
And he was the first
one who discovered
that water vapor,
or carbon dioxide,
or ether, or alcohol
intercepts thermal radiation.
He, as is appropriate
for an Anglo-Irishman,
his source of heat
was a teakettle.
[CHUCKLES]
So he had this hot tea
kettle boiling on a stove.
And then he had a pipe
through which the radiation
from the tea kettle could go.
And he noticed that certain
gases, like CO2 or, especially,
water vapor, would block
most of that heat radiation,
whereas the normal atmospheric
gases, nitrogen and oxygen,
would not.
So we now call the gases that
block the heat greenhouse
gases.
And CO2 is, indeed,
a greenhouse gas.
It's not a very good greenhouse
gas at today's concentrations.
So let me show you.
This is something I
want you to remember.
This is an important slide.
So there's a lot
of history here.
And so there are
two pictures here.
The top picture's Max Planck.
And Max Planck was the
great German scientist who
discovered quantum mechanics.
And amazingly, quantum mechanics
goes back to greenhouse
gas physics, thermal
radiation, just what we're
talking about
today and just what
climate fanatics
don't understand yet,
100 years after Planck.
But Planck understood
it very well.
And Planck was the
first one who was
able to show why the
radiation from warm bodies
has the shape it has.
On this picture to
the left of Planck
and below Schwarzschild--
I'll have more to say about
Schwarzschild in a minute--
is a smooth blue curve.
And what that is--
again, left to right
is wavelength or the
frequency, in this case,
of light, thermal radiation.
And up is the thermal power
that's going out to space.
And so if there were
no greenhouse gases,
the radiation going to space
would be that Planck curve,
that blue curve there.
And that would be the radiation
that keeps the Earth cool.
In fact, that's not what
you observe if you look down
from a satellite.
And we have lots of
measurements now.
What you see is something
that looks a lot
like the black curve
that's below with lots
of jags and wiggles in it.
And that curve was
first calculated
by Karl Schwarzschild, whose
picture is below Planck.
Karl Schwarzschild
was an officer
in the German army
in World War I.
And he did some of
his most creative work
in the trenches on the
Eastern Front, facing Russia.
And he, in fact, produced one
of the first analytic solutions
to Einstein's general
theory of relativity
while he was there
on the front lines.
And alas, he died
before he got home--
not from Russian bullets, but
from an autoimmune disease,
which was really tragic.
But anyway, Schwarzschild
was the theorist
who figured out how to calculate
how the real Earth works
with greenhouse gases.
And it is those
jagged black lines.
Now, the important point here
is that you notice there's also
a red line on this chart.
What the red line
is is what would
happen if you doubled the CO2
concentration from today's
level.
So right in the middle
of these curves--
I'm sorry.
I don't have a
laser pointer here.
But you can see a gap.
And that's due to CO2 absorbing
radiation that would otherwise
cool the Earth.
If you double the
amount of CO2, you
don't double the
size of that gap.
You just go from the black
curve to the red curve,
and you can barely
see the difference.
So the message I want
you to understand,
which practically no
one really understands,
is that doubling CO2 almost
doesn't make any difference.
It goes from that black
curve to the red curve.
And on the basis of
this, we're supposed
to give up our liberties.
We're supposed to
give up the gasoline
engines of our automobiles.
We're supposed to
accept dictatorial power
by Bernie Sanders and
Ocasio-Cortez because
of the difference between
the red and the black curve.
Don't let anyone convince you
that that is a good bargain.
It is a terrible bargain.
The doubling actually does
make a little difference.
It decreases the
radiation to space
by about three watts
per square meter.
In comparison, the
total radiation to space
is about 300.
So it's a 1% effect.
It's actually a
little less than that.
And that's with no clouds.
Clouds make everything
even less threatening.
Finally, let me point out
there is a green curve.
That's what happens if
you take all the CO2 out
of the atmosphere.
No one knows how to do that.
And of course, we'd
all die because plants
die if you take all the
CO2 out of the atmosphere.
But what this curve is telling
you is the greenhouse effect
of CO2 is already saturated.
That's the jargon in science.
It means it's done all
the greenhouse warming
it can already, practically.
And adding, doubling
it practically
doesn't make any difference.
You could quadruple it.
It also practically
makes no difference.
So the CO2 effects are
strongly, strongly saturated.
Now let me move on.
You can take that tiny
difference between those curves
that I showed you, the
red and the black curve,
and calculate the warming
that should happen.
And I was one of the first to
do this, actually, in 1982.
I was the co-author of
one of the first books.
And you can see
on the right panel
there is my calculation and lots
of other people's calculations
since.
It's a bar graph of
the warming per decade
that people have calculated.
The red bar is what's
actually observed.
And on the right is,
I think, for 10 years.
And on the left is 20 years.
But in both cases,
the takeaway message
is the predicted warming, which
everybody is frantic about,
are all grossly over-predicting
the warming compared
to observation, which
is the red bars.
So the observed warmings have
been extremely small compared
to computer calculations over
any interval that you look.
So it's clear that
all of our policies
are based on the models that
you see here that don't work.
The models don't work.
And I think we sort of
know why they don't work,
but no one is
willing to admit it.
Here is-- let's see.
Yeah, here's another
demonstration, again, of that.
The red curve here--
on the bottom is the year.
So I think it starts
in 1975, approximately.
And it goes through 1925 because
some of them are predictions.
So the top curve is predictions
by the international climate
alarm establishment.
And the bottom curves, the
blue and the green curves,
are observations.
And so the blue circles
are measured by balloons.
You probably know that, every
day, thousands of balloons
are launched around the world
in North America, Europe, Asia,
the southern hemisphere.
And they measure the
temperature as you go up.
So we know what the
temperature of the atmosphere
has been doing from these
really good balloon records.
And it's the blue curves.
And the warming observed from
balloons is about a third
of the warming that has
been predicted by models.
And let me also
add, nobody knows
how much of this warming
that's observed is due to CO2.
There's good reason
to think most of it
would be there even
without an increase in CO2,
because we're coming out
of the long Little Ice Age.
And we've been coming out of
that since the early 1800s,
where it got much, much colder.
And the green curve is
measurements from satellites.
Very much like the measurement
of your temporal scanning
thermometer, you can look
down from a satellite
and measure the temperature
of the atmosphere.
So the satellites and the
balloons agree with each other.
And they do not agree
with the models.
This is nice work by John
Christy at the University
of Alabama, Huntsville.
OK.
So the alleged harm from
CO2 is from warming.
And the warming observed
is much, much less
than predictions.
In fact, if the warming is
as small as we're observing,
it's almost
certainly beneficial.
It gives a little bit
longer growing seasons.
You can ripen crops a
little bit further north
than you could before.
And so it's completely good
news in terms of the temperature
directly.
But there's even better news.
Because in reality, by
historical standards,
we're living in a
CO2 famine today.
So let me show you that.
So this is a picture
of our best estimates
of past levels of CO2.
So the vertical scale,
RCO2, is the amount of--
that CO2 in the past was
greater than it is today.
And so you can see on that scale
that over most of the past,
CO2 levels have been five times,
10 times, even 20 times greater
than today.
And during this entire period--
this is the so-called
Phanerozoic,
since the Cambrian era when
we have good fossil records.
So we know pretty
well what life was
doing during that time
from the sediments.
And all of this period with
much higher CO2 levels,
life flourished on Earth.
And in general, it flourished
better when there was more CO2.
So plants really would prefer
to have two, three, four times
more CO2 than we have today.
And you can see plants
already responding to that.
Let me show you an example.
This is the greening of the
Earth measured from satellite.
So this picture shows
areas of the Earth that
are getting greener over
a 20-year period, I think.
My eyes aren't good
enough to read it,
but it's roughly 20 years.
And what you notice
is that everywhere,
especially in arid
areas, the Sahel--
you can see just
south of the Sahara,
it's greening dramatically.
The Western United
States is greening.
Western Australia is greening.
Western India is greening.
And this is almost
certainly due to CO2.
And the reason this
happens is that CO2
allows plants to grow where
50 years ago, it was too dry.
So plants are now
needing less water
to grow than they did
50 or 100 years before.
Let me show you another example
of what more CO2 does in terms
of making plants grow better.
This is a picture of
Dr. Sherwood Idso.
And it was actually an
experiment done here in Phoenix
back in the '80s.
And so this is a pine tree.
I think it's a Mediterranean
pine, eldarica pine.
And on the left,
you'll see a pine tree
growing in the
current CO2 levels
at that time, which
was about three--
ambient was 380,
I believe it says.
And on the right are
more and more CO2.
So you can see that the pine
trees, the more CO2 you put
in them, the faster they grow.
And you can do this
with almost any plant.
The corn, wheat, cotton, they
all grow better with more CO2.
So this is the
so-called pollutant
that you hear about with
the climate emergency.
So let me explain the
basics of why that works.
So if you look
closely at a plant,
you take a low-power
magnifying glass,
you'll see the leaf was
full of little holes.
And the little holes are to
let carbon dioxide diffuse
in from the air into the
moist interior of the leaf,
where the leaf--
with the special
enzyme called rubisco,
one of the most ancient enzymes
in the world and the most
abundant protein in the world--
combines the CO2 with
water to make sugar.
And the energy to run
this little factory,
this chemical factory within the
leaf, is provided by sunlight.
So now, the problem with
this is if you see this hole,
not only is CO2
diffusing in, but there's
a lot more water
vapor inside the leaf
than there is CO2
in the air outside.
So for every CO2 molecule
that diffuses into the leaf,
there are a hundred water
molecules that diffuse out.
So the plant has this
engineering dilemma.
It has to have holes
in its leaf to get
the CO2 that it needs to live.
But those same
holes desiccate it.
They dry it out.
And it, of course, needs
water to live, too.
So what is happening all over
the world now is plants grow.
They are not stupid.
They grow leaves with
fewer holes in them.
And so there's more
CO2 in the air outside,
so they don't need
as many holes.
But they don't leak
as much water either.
So that's why you're seeing
the greening of the Earth.
It's from the plants
themselves taking
advantage of CO2 coming
back to more historically
normal levels.
There's more to say about this.
There's a second
important issue,
which is that the
enzyme I mentioned--
it's called rubisco--
it's very old.
It was probably invented
on the evolutionary scale 3
and 1/2 billion years
ago, so extremely ancient.
And at that time, there
was no oxygen in the air.
And so this poor
enzyme was designed
in a way that makes
it poisoned by oxygen.
And so plants today have a
hard time when there's not
enough CO2 in the air.
This enzyme, which is charged
to make sugar, instead of making
sugar from CO2, it
grabs an oxygen.
And it turns the
oxygen into things
like hydrogen peroxide and
other nasty oxidizing things.
You've heard of
antioxidants in your tea.
They're to handle this problem.
That's why they're generated.
And so if you have more
CO2, this photorespiration
is the jargon that
goes with that.
That is suppressed.
And so plants grow a
lot better with that.
There's a special type of
plant called C4 plants, which
includes American
corn and sugarcane,
that has partially
solved that problem.
But they don't compete well
with the old-fashioned plants.
As the CO2 level goes up,
the old-fashioned ones
without the adaptation
outcompete these C4 plants.
Well, you often-- when
you raise these issues,
the hard scientific issues with
your opponents, the fanatics,
the response is, how can you
say that 97% of scientists
agree that there is a
terrible emergency here
that we have to cope with?
Let's see if I can
get this back again.
And there are several
things you should say.
You should say, first of all, in
science, truth is not voted on.
It's not like voting on a law.
It's determined by how well your
theory agrees with observations
and experiments.
I just showed you that
the theories of warming
are grossly wrong.
They're not even close.
And yet we're making
our policy decisions
based on these
theories, these computer
models that don't work.
So that's one point, is that it
doesn't matter how many people
say there's an emergency.
If it doesn't agree with
the experiment, it's wrong.
And it's definitely wrong.
The second thing is even
when people agree in science,
people think of
scientists as somehow
these incorruptible,
priestly people.
They're not that at all.
They have all the same
faults as everybody else.
And they're frequently wrong.
A good example of that
was continental drift.
When I was a
student in the '50s,
nobody with any
self-respect in geology
admitted to believing
in continental drift,
although it had been
proposed by Alfred
Wegener, a German scientist
in the '20s and '30s.
And it was based on very
good, hard evidence.
An example is shown below.
The fact, for example, that
Africa, and South America,
and India, and Antarctica
fit together like a jigsaw.
So you've taken a jigsaw apart.
So that's pretty
suggestive, I would say.
And secondly, if you look at
the fossils in these continents
from 300 million years
ago, 400 million years ago
today, they go smoothly from
South America to Africa,
or from Africa to India,
or even into Antarctica,
that you find fossils
of the same organisms
even though there's
thousands of kilometers
of sea separating them today.
And so that, again, suggests
that these were connected.
But nevertheless, in spite of
this quite persuasive evidence,
Wegener was scorned and
mocked all his life.
He died falling into a
crevasse in Greenland,
exploring, looking for fossils.
It's sort of a sad ending.
But he was absolutely right.
And the clincher actually
came when we finally
declassified the World War II
North Atlantic magnetic anomaly
data, which we had been sitting
on for 10 years, which showed
a conveyor belt of crust
being formed starting
mid-Atlantic region
and going out,
left and right, toward
America, toward Europe.
So there was
absolutely no question
that the sea floor was
splitting, spreading.
That's the one bit of evidence
that Wegener did not have.
But he had lots
of other evidence
that should have
persuaded people.
So this is just one example.
I could tell you many others
of scientific consensuses
that made no sense.
This one is interesting because
it had no political background.
It was pure science.
But it does illustrate
the fallibility
of scientists and the
groupthink that goes in science.
If you wanted to advance
as a young geologist,
you could write a paper
scorning Wegener in 1950
and get promoted right away,
even though your paper was
completely wrong.
And once you get tenure,
you're there for good.
[LAUGHS]
[LAUGHTER]
So let me-- this is probably
a little too long a lecture.
So let me bring it to a close.
And I'll take some questions.
So the takeaway message
is that the policies
to slow CO2 emissions, they're
based on flawed computer models
which exaggerate warming
by factors of two or three,
probably more.
That's message number one.
So why do we give
up our freedom?
What do we do we give
up our automobiles?
Why do we give up a beefsteak
because of this model
that doesn't work?
And well, at number two,
it's that if you really
look into it, more CO2
actually benefits the world.
So what are we doing?
This beneficial molecule
that's making plants
grow better, that's giving us
a little less harsh winters,
a slightly longer
growing season,
why is that a pollutant?
It's not a pollutant at all.
And we should have the
courage to do nothing
about CO2 emissions.
Nothing needs to be done.
So thank you.
I'll stop at this point, yep.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you, Dr. Happer.
We now have time for some
Q&A. If you have a question,
please raise your hand
and wait for a microphone
to be brought to you.
AUDIENCE: It's a very
interesting conversation.
One of the things that the
environmentalists always forget
is the tremendous
amount of CO2 that
is produced to get
the raw materials,
to make the wind turbines,
to make the solar cells.
But another thing that
I have thought about,
and I've never
seen it discussed--
every one of those things takes
heat out of the atmosphere.
Has anybody ever
figured that out?
The second thing is we talk
about the rise of the ocean,
of the sea level.
Everything we put into the
ocean raises the sea level
a little bit.
And all of the mud
that flows off the land
raises the sea level.
They think it just comes
out from glacier melting,
but there's much more
complicated than that.
WILLIAM HAPPER: Yeah, thank you.
It's true that anything you
make in our modern world
involves CO2 production or
sometimes that carbon actually
goes into the product.
Plastics are made of carbon.
My coat is made of carbon.
With respect to--
the amount of that,
I think it's not negligible.
But the biggest source of CO2
is actually burning fossil fuels
to get energy for
transportation, mostly,
but also electrical power.
Another non-trivial
part is cement-making.
The way you make cement
is you take limestone,
which is calcium carbonate, and
you have to burn oil or coal.
And you bake that out.
And so you get the CO2 from
burning the oil or coal
to heat it, to burn the lime.
And then when you're burning
it, CO2 is coming out.
So what you're doing
is you're baking
CO2 out of the limestone.
So you got a sort of double
whammy from cement manufacture.
I wouldn't call it
a double whammy.
I would call it a double
benefit because, as I said,
it's really good
for life on Earth.
Plants love more CO2.
We're happy with more CO2, too.
We know a lot about
how it affects humans.
It doesn't affect us at all.
As for sea level, sea levels
started to rise around 1800,
at the end of the
Little Ice Age.
And they've been rising
steadily at about 2 millimeters
per year.
2 millimeters is not very much.
You can barely see it.
Well, that's maybe
9 inches a century.
If you go to the sea, a
typical tide is quite a bit
more than 9 inches.
So if 9 inches is
going to bother you,
you've been swindled in the
real estate you've got there.
So nobody knows how long
this rise will continue.
It could easily go
for another century.
Or it could stop in
a couple of years.
One, I was having
lunch with someone.
And they asked, what's
interesting in basic science?
And one of the more
interesting things
is speculation is
that solar activity is
beginning to decrease.
If you look at sunspot
activity, it's definitely less
the last few years.
And we've had these rather cold
winters the last few years.
And one of the possible drivers
of climate is solar activity.
So if there really is going
to be a cooling period--
we had a cooling period,
for example, in the '70s.
I remember, then, reading
about the coming Ice
Age in Newsweek and Time.
And they flipped
immediately 10 years later.
So in physics, we have
a joke which says,
the hardest thing about a theory
is getting the sign right.
And that's been true of--
[LAUGHTER]
--that's been true of
climate for a long time.
Anyway, it could cool in
another 10 or 15 years.
I don't have a strong opinion.
But I'm interested in it.
SPEAKER 3: We have a question
on the speaker's right.
AUDIENCE: I understand
that the original idea was
that CO2 would cause a
slight warming, which
would cause more water vapor,
which was the big greenhouse
gas, which would cause still
more water vapor and more
heating, et cetera, and
a runaway situation.
The fact that the Earth--
well, that the CO2,
its only effect
was to increase the temperature
and start that cycle,
shouldn't it have
been kind of obvious
since, previously, the
Earth has been a lot warmer?
And it didn't start to boil.
WILLIAM HAPPER:
Yeah, absolutely.
The reason the models
get these huge numbers--
and mine had the same flaw--
is because of the
water vapor feedback.
And I think the reason
that those feedbacks
are overestimated--
and I've worked
personally on this,
so I know a lot about it--
is that they don't treat clouds
correctly at the same time.
You can't increase water vapor
without affecting clouds.
And just a few percent
change in cloudiness
completely overwhelms any
change from CO2 or water vapor.
I mean, we're all
familiar with the fact
that if it's a hot summer
day and a cloud comes over,
it cools down.
And if you take that
on a global scale,
it turns out that there's
just exquisite sensitivity
to cloudiness.
Just to follow up on
another allusion you made,
if there really were
this positive feedback,
you can't look at the
geological history of the Earth.
And it could not be as stable.
The climate could
not be as stable
as the geological record
indicates if there
were these positive feedbacks.
Because the temperature would
be shooting up and down,
up and down all of
the time, for example,
because of these changes.
Solar output, I mentioned.
But that's not observed.
The Earth's climate turns
out to be remarkably stable.
If there are feedbacks,
there are probably
negative feedbacks.
And they probably involve
clouds, is my educated guess.
SPEAKER 2: We have time
for one more question.
AUDIENCE: I appreciate the
discussion and the knowledge
that you passed on.
When I look at this
issue, though, it's
more about marketing and
perception than science.
Being retired, I had a
chance to read these studies
as they're published.
And I noticed a
little trend where
they would make a sort
of scientific statement
about climate change.
And two or three
sentences later, then they
go into the projected impacts--
coastal flooding, deserts
everywhere, and so forth.
And the media, of course,
only reads the first paragraph
or whatever, or
whatever they're fed.
And so then they publish that.
And it just scares the
bejesus out of people.
And I have relatives
that believe this stuff.
And you try and explain
what you're telling us.
And with new knowledge,
maybe I can do that.
But you can't get
through to these people.
They're just scared from the
perception and the marketing.
So what do we do?
WILLIAM HAPPER: Well, that's
sort of the key question,
because the scientific support
for it really doesn't exist.
But so many people
are scared now.
And so many people have been
brainwashed since childhood.
I know I watched our children,
our grandchildren in school.
And they get
incessant barrage of,
the world is coming to an end.
You're unlikely to
finish your life
because you're going to fry
and because your dad's driving
an SUV.
And there are a fair
fraction of kids
who are sufficiently independent
thinkers in every generation,
that they laugh this off.
But there are a lot
who take it seriously.
And they go home.
They can't sleep at night.
You've got Greta Thunberg
having hysterics in front
of the mighty of the world.
But she doesn't know anything.
The amazing thing about Greta--
those of you who
know a little bit
about the history
of science, Greta's
the great granddaughter
of Svante Arrhenius.
And Svante Arrhenius
was the first person
to seriously try to calculate
the effects of more CO2.
He thought it would
be good for Sweden.
He was a Swedish chemist.
And it would have
been good for Sweden.
In fact, it is being
good for Sweden.
Sweden, for example, is getting
much higher forestry yields now
than it did 50 years
ago because of more CO2.
But I think he would be appalled
to see his great granddaughter
having hysterics in front
of the world for something
that he was convinced
would be good.
SPEAKER 3: Please join me
in thanking Dr. Happer.
[APPLAUSE]